قد تفكر مرتين قبل ان تنفخ على الكعكه في
حفله عيد ميلادك القادم او اي حفله عيد
ميلاد تدعى اليها بعد هذا الخبر
دانس عالم اغذيه وبروفيسور في جامعه
كليمنسون بولايه كارولينا الشماليه اختبر
كعكه عيد الميلاد قبل وبعد عمليه النفخ
على الشموع ليكتشف مشاهدينا تخيلوا وجود
مئه الى الف فيروس في كل قطره من قطرات
الماء التي تطلق عند النفخ
ينصح بقول في حال حدث هذا الامر امامك
واحرجت واضطررت لتناول قطعه من الحلوى
حلوى عيد الميلاد تم النفخ عليها فما عليك
فعله فقط هو التخلص من طبقه الكريمه
العليا
لهذا الموضوع
هي المشكله انه يوم الخميس احنا احتفلنا
في عيد ميلاد احدى زميلات
ونفخت وبالتالي وانا احب الكريمه
راحت علينا ههه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات